I'm John Dennis I'm running for Congress
against Nancy Pelosi here in San
Francisco California's 12th
congressional district I'm running for a
third time because I still have
outstanding issues with Miss Pelosi
she's consistently floud in civil
liberties she voted to continue funding
the National Security Agency and they're
spying on Americans and it seems like
every election cycle is something that
she votes were something that she says
that dragged me back into the rape my
barometer for success is maybe creating
a new model of an urban Republican one
driven by the Liberty wing libertarian
wing of the Republican Party that I
think is a much better fit for cities
and it's also an opportunity to hold
someone like Nancy Pelosi who holds a
tremendous amount of power hold it to
account for her vote that for her
position
my attempts of I'm sorry to say since
2010 have been unrequited you know for
three elections running cheese refused
to debate and look I mean people around
the country would love to see a debate
between me immense and closely I think
would be a pay-per-view event one more
download the aj+ mobile app and join the
conversation available in your app store
now